well I from Brooklyn New York and
clearly I was shaped by the fact that
I'm a first-generation American my
parents were immigrants my mom and her
family my mom came when she was very
very young in 1921-22 timeframe
something like that from Ukraine there
was this Russian Civil War the
communists against the whites my parents
family my mom's family was caught up in
the middle of it some of them were
killed by the whites some of them were
killed by the communists and they
escaped my dad his family he came from
Lithuania he was a leader of the Jewish
community there who's actually the legal
counsel and he was tipped off that when
the Soviets moved in this was before the
nazi's attacked Russia in 1941 this was
1940 that he was on the KGB or then was
called the NKVD hit list because he was
a leading anti-communist and so he
escaped literally one step ahead of the
NKVD across the Soviet Union spent six
years of the war in China and then came
in 1947 so and he lost two sisters and
he lost his parents to the Nazis and so
I was fashioned by that the fact that
there was just so much blood that had
been spilt in my immediate family that
both of my parents were immigrants they
worshiped the United States and I was
really brought up on God and country an
Orthodox Jew I'm a sixteenth generation
rabbi my son is now the seventeenth
generation one of my sons none of our
family for the last humpty-hump hundred
years has practiced as a rabbi my
father's lawyer as I mentioned but where
we believe in religious values and so on
the one hand we had God and on the other
hand we had this wonderful country that
had made a home for both of my parents
who obviously would probably never have
met if it hadn't been for the United
States cuz they met here which meant I
probably wouldn't have been here
you